Welcome to Module 05. Classification asks "what is in this image?" Segmentation asks "which pixels belong to what?" The output is no longer a single label — it's a label map the same spatial size as the input. That one change reshapes the entire architecture.
The first working idea was Fully Convolutional Networks — FCN, Long et al. 2015. Take a classification backbone like VGG, strip the dense head, replace it with a 1x1 convolution that emits C channels per pixel, and upsample back to the input resolution with transposed convolutions. Every layer is now convolutional.
FCN works, but the naive version is blurry. Downsampling by a factor of 32 then upsampling loses boundary detail. FCN-8s fixes this by adding skip connections from pool3 and pool4 into the decoder, fusing coarse semantic features with finer spatial features. That skip-fusion idea is the seed of everything that follows.
U-Net takes the skip idea to its logical conclusion. Every encoder resolution has a matching decoder resolution, and the full feature map — not just a 1x1 projection — is concatenated across. Designed originally for biomedical images where you have maybe 30 training examples, U-Net's strong inductive bias around locality is exactly what you need when data is scarce.
The practical U-Net checklist: mirror the encoder depth in the decoder, concatenate (don't add) the skip tensors, use a 1x1 conv at the output with `num_classes` channels and no activation (logits), and run softmax inside the loss. Batch-norm or group-norm in both halves. That's 90% of the segmentation code you'll write all year.
DeepLab attacks the same problem from a different angle: atrous, or dilated, convolution. Instead of stacking downsamples, you widen the receptive field by inserting holes in the kernel. A 3x3 conv with dilation rate 6 covers the same receptive field as a 13x13 dense kernel but with nine weights and no extra FLOPs. You keep spatial resolution and still see context.
Atrous Spatial Pyramid Pooling — ASPP — runs four parallel dilated convs at different rates plus a global-pool branch, concatenates, then 1x1 projects. It captures multi-scale context in one shot. DeepLab v3+ combines ASPP with a lightweight U-Net-style decoder — the current default for high-accuracy segmentation on natural images.
Loss functions matter more in segmentation than in classification. Per-pixel cross-entropy is the baseline, but class imbalance destroys it — if 95% of pixels are "background", the model learns to predict background everywhere and still hits 95% accuracy. You need a loss that rewards recall on the minority classes.
Dice loss, derived from the Dice coefficient, measures overlap and is naturally balanced — it ignores the overwhelming true negatives and focuses on the intersection. Pair it with cross-entropy in a weighted sum (classic split is 0.5 CE + 0.5 Dice) and you get stable optimization plus good boundary recall.
Focal loss adds a down-weighting factor `(1 - p_t)^γ` to cross-entropy so easy pixels contribute less gradient. With γ=2 it's the go-to for heavily imbalanced medical segmentation. Boundary loss — distance-transform-weighted — is the right tool when thin structures like vessels or cracks matter more than interior area.
Post-processing: conditional random fields, especially DenseCRF, used to be standard after FCN. With modern networks and enough data, CRFs buy you less than 1 mIoU and double your inference time, so most production pipelines drop them. The exception is medical imaging with tiny datasets — there CRF post-processing still pays off.
Evaluation: mean IoU, not accuracy. Per-class IoU first, then macro-averaged across classes. Report per-class numbers always — a model with 90 mIoU that scores 10 on "pedestrian" is a liability. Pixel accuracy is misleading on imbalanced datasets and should never be the primary metric.
Data pipeline notes. Augmentations must be applied consistently to both image and mask — same random crop, same horizontal flip, same rotation angle. Use nearest-neighbor interpolation on masks (never bilinear) to preserve class IDs. tf.data pipelines should do augmentation in `map()` with `num_parallel_calls=tf.data.AUTOTUNE`.
Class weighting vs loss reweighting vs sampling: three levers that achieve similar ends. Sampling (oversample minority crops) is the most sample-efficient; class weighting is simplest to implement in the loss; Dice/Focal are the most robust across datasets. Mix-and-match — don't expect a single lever to fix severe imbalance.
The labs in this module build up in sequence. Start with a tiny FCN on the Oxford-IIIT Pet dataset. Move to U-Net on the same data — you'll see immediate boundary-quality gains. Then add atrous convolution and ASPP, and finally a DeepLab v3+ recipe. Final lab: segmentation metrics and error analysis — per-class IoU, confusion matrix, qualitative failure-case review.
One recurring pitfall: mask dtypes. TensorFlow expects integer class masks for sparse cross-entropy (`tf.int32` or `tf.int64`), but many datasets ship 8-bit PNGs whose pixel values happen to be class indices in 0–N. Cast explicitly on ingest — silent dtype mismatches show up as "NaN loss after 3 steps" and eat a day of debugging.
That's the core of segmentation. The encoder-decoder pattern with skip connections dominates; atrous convolutions extend receptive field without losing resolution; the loss function is where you buy class balance; and pixel-consistent augmentation is the data-pipeline rule you cannot break. Head to the first lab — FCN on Oxford-Pets — and we'll see the encoder-decoder idea in code.